to have an easier life as a startup as
an entrepreneur you have to have let's
say five seven years as an entrepreneur
you have to understand the best
practices and methodologies and
management skills of building a startup
and you need to have maybe the same
amount of expertise in a certain domain
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders and meet owad shakir awad is an
entrepreneur currently running think up
a digital platform to support enhance
and accelerate other founders journeys
hawaii is also the founder of things and
network of iot devices he ran his family
office for the past 15 years building
the success of his late father at
888.com
i'm really excited to talk to you about
your own journey
and transitioning you know part family
office part investor in startups and
funds uh also an entrepreneur this is
the second large endeavor and then
you're starting
from think so looking at iot and
networks and then transitioning now to
digital acceleration for people and
entrepreneurs and ideas and so a lot to
uncover uh under the that underlying
question of of why do you do what you're
doing and who are you a chaked so i
think we should start there you know
if you look at yourself how you know how
do you think throughout your own
priorities your own passions what do you
care about
well i i think the the division i start
with a vision uh a bold vision
uh trying to make some breakthroughs
uh
things that maybe other people seem to
be a bit impractical impossible
a bit
too big
you know i think that's what drives me
that's what makes me passionate and uh
makes me wake up in the morning and go
to sleep if i if i manage to to get some
sleep
and most recently in in in your most
recent endeavor you're looking at people
and entrepreneurs as a community and
sort of acceleration as a mode of growth
how did how did that come about for you
this passion for people on acceleration
well being an entrepreneur four or five
years ago starting another venture
i
came across this issue of everything is
going very slow you have to research and
research and come up with ideas and
pitch it to the market and then go back
to the drawing table
and drawing board and um i said why
isn't there uh a platform to help us do
all of that uh very quickly
and it turned out to be you know such a
huge project
uh to lay out everything for uh
entrepreneurs to make their life easier
to make innovation much easier and
faster
tell me a little bit more about your own
your own personal experience that that
have led you to this sort of realization
because a part of the realization is not
only that you
are that there is a problem but that
it's a problem that that you can solve
at scale with with your current endeavor
so what led to that understanding
i started another venture as you
mentioned things building a network for
iot devices a very big vision
and we
researched you know every vertical in
iot space
smart homes smart cities trans smart
transportation smart logistics and every
time you take a time you know every time
you dive into another vertical it takes
time and you have to come up with new
use cases new solutions you have to talk
to different people it takes a lot of
time i said look we're in a digital
world why doesn't everything happen
within a click
no i want every everything to be instant
sure just like when you're ordering food
you know it's instant 30 minutes and you
get everything you want
why can't that be for startups
that's where we came
what did you understand why why is it
hard for it to be like that for startups
because you know i think that in order
to
to have an easier life as a startup as
an entrepreneur you have to have let's
say five seven years
as an entrepreneur you have to
understand the best practices and
methodologies and management skills of
building a startup and you need to have
maybe the same amount of expertise in a
certain domain whatever your domain is
cyber fintech whatever if you don't have
both of that you're gonna be you're
gonna have very hard life very tough
life as an entrepreneur you need to have
the guidance the best practices the
methodologies then you have to look for
data
regardless even of your experience if
you're entering a new domain you have to
look into the data how is the market
structured what's its size you have to
know the customers
and you know you need to have the
network the customers and and
and the expert domain experts in every
aspect branding a competitive analysis
go to market
and on top of all of that you need to
get the funding right
so an entrepreneur has lots and lots of
issues
and we're trying to build the platform
to make them go through all of that um
easier
so
did the idea come to you you know by
happenstance were you thinking about
this for a while because you know a lot
of entrepreneurs go through adversity
and and a lot of what you're talking
about but but there's a
leap from
experiencing it yourself to actually
going and saying my next venture is
going to
attempt to solve this at scale
yeah well it was quite um
easy for me or straightforward you know
making the the transition you know when
you have an idea when you have a a
passion when you you want to create
something new
um there isn't a but you know the other
thing there isn't uh do or not oh try
you just do it
so i just jump ahead and you do it you
see it could make such a big difference
in entrepreneurs life
you just go ahead and do it no matter
how big the task is
so tell me a little bit about the sort
of the the product or or
the offering through think up
the offering
well um you know you get the digital
platform that uh
lays out for you the entire uh
startup journey
at the moment we focus on early stage so
we're trying to divide
the the journey of the startup into
building blocks
you know like searching your customers
and market research and doing the
competitive analysis and go to market
strategy
even though every startup is unique and
has a unique story
all of them has probably the same
template the same generic tasks that
they need to do they are already best
practices and the methodologies how to
create startups
you know
and um we're building the platform to
help you navigate
uh understand what is the current task
that you need to do
how to do it
uh with lots of uh guidance and examples
and even data
we're not just telling you go ahead and
research your customers we're trying to
tell you who are your customers what are
your pay what are their pains
uh what are they buying now
uh
trying helping you in persona mapping um
okay we're not just throwing you out
there with a blank board and
just go ahead and do competitive
analysis no we're trying to tell you
whatever domain you are
who are the current competitors we're
trying to give you some a head start
so it's not just guiding you
how does your roadmap look like what do
you need to do we're helping you how to
do it
we're providing some of the data
and if all of that doesn't help we still
have the network of experts and other
founders and also our own startup
success managers to help you
complete each of the steps
in your journey
so just for clarification are you giving
them
more of a structure for how to
think through these problems or the
different techniques for
what are you know the best practices for
researching a user persona or are you
actually
there side by side with them as they are
researching and you're giving and you're
doing part of the research yourself
yeah it's both it's both you start with
the structure what's need to be done
what is the order of the tasks and then
how to do it guide them through help
them provide data
and trying to have some outcomes and
deliverables it's not just an e-learning
platform how to do stuff it's
making outcomes okay
generating the market research
generating the competitive analysis
generating the customer research
generating the pitch deck at the end
okay
fast and accurate and easy
right so
you know some some investors and some
entrepreneurs will say that you know the
very essence of entrepreneurship
is to be able to
to constantly iterate and to ask these
questions and and things only get harder
as the startup grows more difficult
decisions need to be made
the the world becomes more complicated
many more variables are thrown in the
air so how do you find you know the how
do you find sort of the educational
piece of taking the entrepreneur on a
journey
how how big of a part is it today with
think up how or how big of a part do you
think it should be in general in a in in
your interaction with the with the
entrepreneurs
they will still iterate
they will still iterate it's not going
it's not by using our platform it will
guarantee just going from step one
through two three four five and that's
it it will still iterate and learn new
things all along the way
but uh still it will be much more
structured and helping them with the
blind spots
and things they should have done in the
beginning
you know
lots of people just go ahead without
planning without creating the strategy
or the business plan so even though you
get guidance and help and data you will
still iterate you will still pivot and
make mistakes from some of the time
but hopefully it would be you know much
easier and much less prone to errors
right right
so in today's world do you get to work
with with some of the entrepreneurs do
you get to see the
the journey that they're on and sort of
think back to your own journey what has
this experience been like for you
absolutely so we've had uh
almost 100 entrepreneurs on our platform
wow
we're still on you know early poc stage
uh it's amazing to see entrepreneurs
from throughout the world
from israel and pakistan and india and
the united states and south africa
each and every one with his own idea
and
you know it's tough it's tough for them
at the moment it's it's not very easy
for us to guide them but it's very
fulfilling you know once you get
everything straight or most of the
things straight
and you help them show their blind spots
and how to do things
you know you save them so much effort
time and agony
and we can bring them forward so it's
very fulfilling
and we hope to see
many more entrepreneurs you know uh
complete uh
you know what we call the id stage okay
building the initial frame business
framework for the startups
and hopefully getting them
funding and the first customer which
will mean you know that we're successful
that we're
putting them on the right track
so so i'd love to go a little bit higher
in the air and then dive back deep
about the product so so if we're looking
at sort of the the vision of of this and
if you're looking at your own vision and
you know if we're even you know looking
eight years down the line yeah so how
does the world look in eight years with
think up for you great great question so
we want to be uh the standard or the the
go to platform when you have an idea
okay like today for google take for
example uh google when you have uh
something that you want to look up you
go straight to google no question about
it
five ten years from the dictionary
yeah exactly to google things up
five ten years from now we would like
that if you have an idea
the go-to place is gonna be think up
you're not just gonna do it like today
just google up things or call your
friends
or go to an accelerator if you have an
idea you will go to think up this is how
you're going to create your startup this
is how everyone will create their
startup
and
hopefully um innovation could be 10
times easier
using our platform
and um
you know innovations is going to pick up
it's going to be much more rapid
much more rapid
why do you think that is because it
sounds like you're talking about a a
general trend
of innovation why do you think
innovation is going to be much more
rapid in the future
when you
uh when you use
more and more digital tools
to help people and automate things
it's going to be much easier no you
don't have the questions of
where do i learn how to create a startup
where do i start i need to read all of
that stuff
i'm not sure how to do uh market
research i need to go and look up data
in google about a certain vertical i
have a vision about drones and logistics
okay good luck go and look
who's the expert on that subject go
ahead and look for data gonna take you
months and once you get an idea you'll
go back and change it again and again
and
but what if you have a digital platform
to tell you straight from day one what
to do and help you to go through the
steps very very quickly
you know right and so obviously you know
i i think that
you know i remember as a kid i was
reading eric reese's book the lean
startup right and and it almost felt
like you know he was taking a lot of
these fundamental ideas of
of what agile is and what you know
different but but he was putting them in
a structure and some methodology that
was that i was able to constantly refer
to
and and see where i'm at in relative to
this framework
so that i can then best decide on what
my next step should be is this sort of
what you're doing at scale to any
entrepreneur that wants to have some
framework in mind
yeah yeah exactly so
there's lots and lots of people and
companies trying to help entrepreneurs
lots of books
and lectures and entrepreneurship
programs
and professional services and
accelerators and advisors
what if we can digitize it digitize the
knowledge you know if you could have an
ai startup advisor
that has seen tens of thousands of
startups and for the the next startup
for the next entrepreneur it can tell
him what to do
okay recommendations
suggestions and recommendations every
everything will be much faster
and uh much more accurate
right and obviously there's always the
trade-off between generalized approach
and the specific approach because yeah
it will be very hard to get an ai to be
able to give that detailed exact advice
on the specific pain point that the
entrepreneur is solving but if they're
able to guide them on where to even
prioritize the time and thinking that's
a big deal
yeah yeah there's always you know we're
talking about innovation so you always
bring something new to the table
obviously
you're not doing the same thing as the
other millions entrepreneurs have done
before you so you can guess everything
it's not predictable but let's say 60 70
percent of your work is probably
predictable if i have seen 1 000 of
fintech startups probably the 1001
startup that will come across me i can
give him some recommendations and
suggestions i can tell him what to do
and what not to do i'm not going to be
100 right i can't tell him everything
but i can tell 60 70 80 of uh of the
stop
right
so if we're looking back to sort of your
own
journey why do you care so much i mean i
care about startup succeeding i've gone
through some entrepreneurial journey
with myself but but why why do you wake
up sort of passionate for this thing to
work why does this need to work for you
first of all you know it's it's my
creation like a baby it runs through my
my blood
uh every single minute
uh every time that we we we crack
something we we solve something we make
some progress
every time there's a new entrepreneur on
boarding every time entrepreneur says
thank you you've done such such a great
help for me such a great service that's
that's uh worth everything so uh
gives us you know great pleasure
and it's it's a great vision you know
it's not just changing a certain
industry a certain niche it's changing
the entire world
bringing in
a new infrastructure for every
innovator out there
no you know what kind of impact that's
an impact for the entire humanity not
just uh
for a specific industry
right you're saying that pace of
innovation right obviously as an
investor you got to work with different
entrepreneurs in different niches and
you've seen sort of what what's
happening with them but here you're
saying let's look at you know if we're
looking at sort of the pyramid
the most foundational layer is sort of
this infrastructure
for where innovation happens and if
you're able to
to even improve on that by by a percent
in the world
that will have a dramatic ripple effect
up the pyramid and will allow many more
to go above that that level right
exactly we're not helping just uh
fintech or cyber or iot or logistics or
fashion tech or real estate tech we're
helping everyone
everything based on it's a methodology
right and it's a framework rather than
just a niche product
what's been what's been the most you
know i guess interesting piece of it for
you that
maybe was trivial maybe wasn't if you're
looking back at the last few years
running this what what have you learned
that maybe surprised you
or is not trivial
um
you know it's
it's an amazing journey
and
i learn every day i learn new stuff i
learn for example you know you have to
be careful even if you have lots of
resources
uh i'm not the average user not the
average entrepreneur even though you
have uh kind of unlimited resources
resources are still limited you need to
be focused not try to give too much in
your product you have to be focused
and
you know i've been learning lots of
stuff about from starting from product
design to product management to how to
manage a team
and um
you know so many things operation wise
and
you know we're building a new language a
new set of tools of
how to create a digital accelerator it's
a new term it hasn't been done before
with more than a and i love you
mentioning it you're you're in your poc
stage but you've already had more than
100 entrepreneurs experience experience
that's obviously yeah and you know we're
looking at innovation in the world and i
i've been enjoying watching shark tank
the last few days i don't know why i've
gotten into a shark tank marathon but
you know it's inspiring to me to see how
so many entrepreneurs around the world
can innovate on anything
and
and at the end it's the same fundamental
questions the same fundamental
philosophy for how to
build on top of this foundational idea
and it sounds like you're coming in and
saying it's great that you have this
foundational idea but now let's
structure it and let's
position you in the best way possible
for success which is not not trivial you
know i've been uh on
a presentation a picture of a panel uh
with uh someone who ran an accelerator
and she ran in a pitch deck night there
were a few entrepreneurs like me and she
told me what are you gonna have a
methodology that's gonna fit every
startup in the world that's insane
that's impossible and then she said to
the next uh presenter after me
she told them
there's a template on our website please
make sure your pitch is uh
just into the template so she has a
template you know pidgeot has a template
so
the journey has a template
right and i think that maybe some people
may may be conflating template or
structure with them a a sure fire system
there is no sure fire away most
entrepreneurs will fail that's that's
the reality that's statistics
the question is are there best practices
that are worth knowing to help make
things easier right and it sounds like
you're taking those best practices and
you're making them accessible to people
around the world and it's not about
creating
the best it's not about creating you
know a success story it's about creating
the best opportunity for a success story
a lot i really want to thank you for
wonderful 20 minutes very insightful i i
wish best of luck to you and and all the
entrepreneurs on your platform
thank you very much for the conversation
and best of luck
perfect thanks for having me michael
thank you very very much
[Music]